[Aplausos]
no soy
esta última semana la justicia turca ha
anunciado su intención de cerrar la
mayor asociación feminista del país se
trata de la plataforma para haremos los
feminicidios y se les acusa entre otras
cosas de ser inmorales e ir en contra de
los valores de la familia
[Música]
no luchan en contra de los feminicidios
sino que luchan en contra de nuestros
esfuerzos vemos que es una posición muy
contradictoria aunque tendrían que
luchar en contra de los perpetradores y
los asesinos vemos que luchar en contra
nuestra
en esta tierra se asesinan las mujeres
porque quieren tomar sus propias
decisiones y los tribunales les dan a
los asesinos unos descuentos especiales
por ejemplo porque visten bien porque se
arrepienten porque habían sido
provocados por desgracia vivimos en un
sistema extremadamente patriarcal man y
así lo reflejan nuestros jóvenes desde
hace varios años el gobierno de turquía
no cuenta el número de feminicidios que
ocurre en un año del país y la única
situación que lo hace
plataformas para demostraste minicipios
según ellas
a más de una mujer a manos de su novio
marido padre hermano o desconocido james
de quien ya nadie tiene
en nuestro país los asesinatos a mujeres
están subiendo sin fin y por eso estamos
aquí para protestar por todo lo que
sufrimos cada día por el simple hecho de
ser mujeres
[Música]
tanto las que estamos aquí nos
levantamos por la mañana con noticias de
una mujer que ha sido asesinada cerca no
es de casos aislados de lejos no ocurren
por todos lados sufrimos miedo a salir a
la calle de noche y por eso luchamos
para poder vivir
turquía hace algo más de un año abandonó
la convención de estambul un acuerdo
internacional para la protección de las
mujeres desde ese momento el número de
feminicidios y asesinatos de mujeres no
ha hecho más que incrementar en el país
anatolia